so you uh just a small tangent on this
you you uh face the mountain uh you have
four uh uh bjorn well first of all you
arm wrestle them yeah it's interesting
to ask um so this is the mountain from
the game of thrones uh a strong man one
of the strongest people in the world for
tom the strongest person in the world
what was it like i know sort of you guys
maybe weren't going one thousand percent
but what's it like well he probably
wasn't going a thousand percent
yeah but like what it's interesting to
think
what does that strength feel like so
it's a it's a specialized strength in
another sport yeah what does it feel
like
what how strong
was he what are some kind of
deep insights he drawn from that battle
i feel like
if we were to go back
a thousand years
and if you give him armor
and a two-handed sword
he will just
rip across the landscape
and no one will stop him so this is the
boxing match you came to but there's
also a video of them arm wrestling
what a titan though what a titan uh you
know a guy like that
tall
yeah strong fit disciplined
i mean he is uh he's quite a warrior 119
pounds oh yeah yeah he's
he's incredibly impressive uh i i really
like happ thor and i like eddie hall too
and i was just so i'm just so caught up
with the drama
okay so
so eddie hall and half thor bjornson yes
two of the strongest legendary strong
men that we have uh
at you know and they were the coolest
they were the top when strongman was
really super cool
uh
i don't know all the details
but they legit hit each other
like legit so i think it kind of stems i
don't know like like i say i'm not right
there with them but
uh
eddie won
the the world's strongest man event or
something one year and like and the
thing it was one of those victories
where
hapthor you know was not accepting of
his defeat
okay and there was a little bit of back
and forth basically from what i
understand they were going to fight like
the knight of the world's strongest man
and they got kind of got pulled apart
and this uh
this heat between them got translated
into a potential boxing match
so it's very real it's a very real fight
so you have the two strongest dudes on
the planet you're gonna fight each other
so so i've been like you know because
arm wrestling is strong man it's it's
kind of similar communities uh
who who do you got
if you if you were giving me financial
advice oh jesus i am so bad i always
call it wrong they're very different uh
i i see uh
hap thor's being you know
eddie hall is slimming down is that what
yeah as well i see hap thor is a bit
more regimented
um but i see eddie hall as like way more
barbaric and like a little i think he's
a little bit more athletic
app thor is bigger and uh and you know
they've chosen slightly different paths
to prepare for the match but but what
happened was like they were about to
fight
and eddie hall blew his bicep
so me i was getting ready for lavonne in
december we were supposed to arm wrestle
in december but
he's got his movie
and so i was like okay i can kind of get
away from the sport just a little bit
broaden my base
that happened and i was like
oh an opportunity you stepped down an
opportunity to fight i'm like i'll do it
so how much training you uh you you
trained a little bit so can you tell
about your own decision to do that what
was the training like what was it yes
like oh it was so much fun it was so
much fun
uh so basically
i made a funny video and i sent it to
the organizers of core sports that i
would do it i'm like i'll do it i'm sure
they got a thousand people who wanted to
do it
but i'm like i'm like listen i'm like i
i'm an old man like i'm gimped up like
everywhere outside the arm wrestling
lanes
uh i said but but i will 100 like if you
let me fight him i'll i'll give it my
all
and uh
and whatever they didn't get back to me
they're like whatever okay so then so
then they call me on a friday like five
weeks before the event
and they're like hey devin were you
serious and i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i'm like yes i was serious yeah i'll
do it and they're like okay
um
they're like it's down to you and like
two other people uh we'll get back to
you in a day or two but you would do it
i'm like okay so they got back to me on
sunday
like so right away i'm like skipping
rope and i'm like and i'm so i only arm
wrestle legs that's all i do so what was
your you did some yeah
striking training yeah so i went to um
this guy that he was he was awesome zach
ben bushida there uh that was it from
from tristar do you know for us the
hobby
uh
and yes people in the comments i will
interview him on this podcast people
he's brilliant
right he's an incredible guy so right
away like i had no idea about the fight
community across canada really
and i got like
by the fifth message that said you must
train with ferraz uh i was like okay
called him up he was incredible right
away he's like yeah you can come and
we'll just work with you
so
i got i got the call i called him on
like monday
at two o'clock
by like seven o'clock i had my things
packed and i went to montreal and i
spent four weeks in in the fighter dorms
just humbling yourself yeah every day
just getting punched in the face you
know uh over and over uh
going for runs with all like they're all
like olympians and pro fighters living
in the dorms super cool dudes they were
so good to me yeah there's a good video
of you and uh for us uh just talking
yeah i don't i don't remember which
stage this was but this is early but you
were already beginning to get humbled oh
man i knew i mean i knew what i was
getting into like i knew it was i knew
it was going to be a losing battle but i
felt like the opportunity to fight thor
like how cool is that like i had i i had
to say i had to do it
um
i loved the process and i learned a lot
from doing it
like the dorms i want to do something
like that with arm wrestling i think
we're big enough now that we can have
these kind of uh you know dorms frat
houses whatever you want to call it
what's the dorm like so you're basically
staying there yeah food is there yeah so
you can you can you mentioned uh what
was the word use administration yeah
exactly that's it so it removes all of
that makes it so simple you can just
focus you know the gym is here you live
here yeah
you know but your life becomes simple
yeah so there's a guy named jimmy pedro
here in america he's a famous uh coach
there's a place up in boston he has kind
of a dorm like that too yeah and it that
becomes essential
when the community is small but you're
trying to do epic things right like
winning olympic gold yeah so you have to
really put the people together
in these kind of minimalist conditions
when they just focus on the training
focus focus focus yes um
yeah it wasn't enough time i mean i
trained for about yes three or four
weeks
uh but i love the journey and um
what are some of the fun things you
enjoy so you did mostly striking did you
uh yeah i guess it was yeah it was
boxing it was straight up boxing yeah
what what are some things that were
transferable what are some cool things
you learned from that
so from the world of armor have you
taken anything back like some
training regimens ideas about training
even just
even
movements because for us is a
unique mind as well for training
yeah
i i don't know i mean i've gone very far
down the path of arm wrestling
uh boxing and arm wrestling are very
different they're they're very different
sports uh
the the physicality required is very
different uh you know
the mentality i mean it's fighting so
it's another form of fighting which is
cool the the big things that i took back
from it
the things that i loved about it was i
had to run again
you know
so really work on endurance yeah
yeah i was going for runs with guys in
the dorms and they'd
they would just destroy me just like it
was
so bad
uh
did you uh
like how did you feel in the actual
boxing in terms of endurance
were you able to no
it's just torture it was it was terrible
and and the thing is is it was so crazy
for me because
i really was good once upon a time yeah
i really was like physically like i had
incredible full-body endurance you know
um but you know being so specialized i
realized how much i had slipped
and
yeah it was it was fun to try and regain
i think it's affected my body
composition i think since that training
i've become much more lean
uh i think was a very healthy thing for
me to do like health-wise like i always
think that you know when you're far away
from competition it's really good to
kind of spread out really good so i
think that in that way also for your
mind yeah yeah just like mm-hmm
yeah
yeah it's just something about clearing
your
i i think you've talked about this is
like uh
you're basically taking steps back
before you take steps forward is uh i
forget how you call the wave yeah yeah
under
you know you have to go under you gotta
you know if you wanna go above the line
you have to spend some time beneath it
and yeah i was definitely beneath the
line for a long time yeah uh but
mountain i mean
like the interesting thing was as
incredible as he is
uh you know like what a monster and i
think if you hadn't had him
training in boxing you know for a long
time and like from his youth i think he
would you know the guy could be world
champion
but
you know to be so specialized and then
to switch you're at a disadvantage yeah
and and also like i know
from just fighting guys in the gym
in tristar
some of those guys were way scarier
it's for real like as scary as thor is
like there's guys in that tristar gym
that don't look like anything
that would murder me
much worse
much worse yeah but also you know that's
the difference being in the gym and
under the lights too i mean uh gsb is an
example of george st pierre is an
example of somebody that maybe doesn't
look
yeah terrifying is that a tristar yep
he's he trains the tristar but he's
quite he's super nice
super uh humble but is terrifying when
he's fighting right it's dominating
people
you